There's another tool that provides the
same kind of information as host does,
but in a more technical and
complete form.
So the host tool shows more human
readable information, spelled out in
English sentences like, such and so
name is an alias for this other name.
Or this name has address 52.25.84.3.
The dig tool shows the same
information more or less.
But in a form that's more readable for
scripts and
is closer to the way that it's stored
in the DNS server's configuration file.
Let's take a look.
So here I did dig www.udacity.com,
and here we see a question
section that says, what is the request
that we sent to the DNS system?
And an answer section that
says what we got back.
See, here's the name that
host says was an alias.
We can see as we saw before
alias is done with CNAME.
And here's the name that host
said it was an alias too.
And likewise, these names have
A records with the IP addresses.
But dig also gives us other information.
It tells us what server
answered our query.
It tells us some metadata like,
when the query was answered.
And it also includes some other
fields that say how the query worked.
We won't go into those in this course.
But it's worth noting that you can get a
lot of information out of DNS this way.